Herkese de selamlar sevgili 9. sınıflar.
Nasılsınız bakalım? Umarım keyiflerin
her şey yolunda gidiyordur. Geldik 6.
temamıza. İstatistiksel araştırma süreci
diyeceğiz bu ders. Önce tabii özürümüzle
başlayalım. Bir süredir eee video
gelmiyordu 9. sınıflara malum. Eee
sürekli yorumlarda bunu dile getirdiniz.
Eee tabii içeriklerle alakalı bir
sıkıntımız oldu sevgili gençler. E
inşallah önümüzdeki sene 10. sınıf
olduğunuzda kitabımız gelecek. ki
inşallah bir aksilik olmazsa ve
dolayısıyla kitapla beraber günü gününe
aksatmadan eee vaktini geçirmeden bam
bam bam daha seri hızlı bir şekilde
gideceğiz inşallah önümüzdeki yıl
diyorum ama bu yılda tabii ki de hemen
kaldığımızı eee toparlayacağız. Eksik
yerlerimizi halledeceğiz. Şimdi 6.
temamızda ilk başlığımız tek değişkenli
nicel veri, bağlam vesaire bunları
anlatacağım. Araştırma sorusunun
özelliklerinden bahsedeceğim. Yine son
yazılımızda bunlar karşımıza tabii ki de
gelecek. Yine kendi üslubumuzla, kendi
anlatım tarzımızla hazırsan haydi
başlıyoruz. Şimdi tek değişkenli nicel
veriden başlayalım. Olayı bağlamından
koparmayalım. Nasıl? Yeni müfredata
uygun şakalar başladı mı aranızda?
Bağlamından koparmayalım. Birazdan
bağlamı da göreceğiz. Şimdi gençler eee
tek değişkenli nicel veride ne var?
Nicel verinin ne demek olduğunu önce bir
öğrenelim. Şimdi bir grubun
özelliklerinin sayılması veya
ölçülmesiyle elde ettiğimiz verilere biz
nicel veri diyoruz. Yani nicel veri
nedir? Sayısal veri. Yani sayısal
demiyorlar da nicel diyorlar. Biliyorsun
nicelik var, nitelik var ya. Buradaki
işte sayısal
bilgiler nicelik bilgileridir. Tamam.
Yani nicel veri diyoruz sayısal olan eee
arkadaşlara. Şimdi burada aşağıda mesela
bir sınıftaki öğrencilerin matematik
dersindeki birinci yazılı notlarının
olduğu nokta grafiği nicel veriye nedir?
Bir örnek olarak gösterilebilir. Neden?
Çünkü burada sayısal bilgiler
alabiliyoruz. Anlaştık mı? Peki hemen
bununla ilgili geçiyorum ikinci
başlığıma. O da bağlam. Şimdi olayın
bağlamını bir anlayalım. Verilere dayalı
bilgi üretmek için kullanılan gerçek
yaşam durumlarına aslında biz bağlam
diyoruz. Yani bağlam ne demek? gerçek
yaşam durumu demek diye de aklınızda e
tutabilirsiniz. Şimdi olayı bağlamından
koparma hani mevzudan ayrılma tamam mı?
Esas mevzuyu eee hatırla sürekli demek.
Hani olayından bağ olayı bağlamından
kopar mı diyoruz ya mevzu buradan
kaynaklı. Şimdi istatiksel istatiksel
araştırma bağlamla ilgili araştırma
soruları oluşturularak başlar. Şimdi biz
bu ünitede gençler derdimiz ne?
Öncelikle onu da söyleyeyim. Derdimiz
eee araştırma yapacağız. Hani veri
analizi falan hep 7'de 8'de falan
gördünüz ya. Bunun aslında bir üst
konusu gibi düşünebilirsiniz. Çok daha
eee ayrıntılı konusu. Şimdi bizim
derdimiz araştırma yapmak. İstatiksel
istatistiksel bilgiler elde etmek. E bu
da nasıl başlayacak? Tabii ki de
araştırma sorusu oluşturularak başlaması
lazım. İşte bu sebeple gerçek yaşam
durumlarından yola çıkılarak bağlamın
belirlenmesi ve araştırmanın bağlama
göre oluşturulması gerekiyor. Şimdi
burada tabii hani bir soru oluşturacağım
ya. E soru oluşturmadan önce bana bir
bağlam yani bir gerçek hayat durumu
gerekiyor. Onunla ilgili çünkü bir soru
oluşturacağım. Tamam. Mevzu bu. Bağlam
dediğimiz şey gerçek hayat durumu.
Birazdan sorusunu çözeceğiz. Şimdi
istatiksel araştırma soruları tek nicel
değişkene uygun olarak hazırlanır. Yine
bu araştırma sorularının özelliklerini
de birazdan
detaylandıracağız. Eee tek nicel
değişkene tabii uygun sorular olması
lazım. Mesela ne bileyim boy uzunluğunu
araştıracağım. Yani sadece boy uzunluğu
gibi ya da kilolar vesaire işte. Tamam.
Tek bir nicel yani bir soru soracağım 60
tane bilgi karşılık cevap gelmemesi
lazım. Bu yüzden tek nicel değişkene
uygun olarak hazırlanır. Sorular
doğrultusunda verileri toplama planı
yapılır. Planımızı yapacağız ve verilere
ulaşacağız. Son olarak da topladığımız
verileri analiz ederek yorumlayacağız.
Yani sana şu an konu sıralamasını
verdik. Tamam. Şimdi ama biz neredeyiz?
Daha soru kısmındayız. Araştırma sorusu
hazırlıyoruz. Şimdi hemen bir sorumuz
var. Gerçek yaşam durumları ve
bağlamlar. Bunları birbiriyle
eşleştireceğiz. Değil mi? Ne demiş bak?
Tabloda verilen gerçek yaşam durumlarına
karşılık gelen tek nicel değişkenli veri
toplamayı gerektiren bağlamları
eşleştiriniz. Şimdi bak sorularda daha
iyi anlayacaksın mevzuyu. Mesela gerçek
yaşam durumu nedir? Burada ne görüyorum
ben? Spor. Tamam. Diyorum ki şimdi bu
spora uygun bir bağlam arayayım. İçinde
sporla alakalı bir şey geçmesi lazım.
Yani genel anlamıyla bu şekilde
söyleyebilirim. Mesela A'ya bakalım.
Türkiye'nin 2024 yılına kadar
düzenlediği olimpiyatlardaki madalya
sayısı altına tam bir sporla alakalı
bağlam. Dolayısıyla ben 1'i A ile
eşleştirebilirim. İkinciye baktım. Okuma
alışkanlığı yazıyor. Şimdi okuma, okuma,
kitaplar hani bunlarla ilgili bir şey
görmem lazım. Mesela Edirne'ye bak. Son
20 yılda ülkemizde satılan barkodlu
roman ve hikaye kitabı sayısı. Barkodlu
dedi yani yasal. Tamam. Korsana. Hayır.
Şimdi burada e okuma alışkanlığını bize
gösterebilecek bir bağlam mı bu? Evet.
Hani ne kadar fazla kitap satıldıysa
mesela a diyeceğiz ki okuma alışkanlığı
artıyor galiba. Dolayısıyla 1i a ile
2'yi de Edirne ile eşleştirebilirim.
Üçüncü de otomobil demiş. Gerçek yaşam
durumu. Otomobille ilgili şimdi bir
bağlam arıyoruz. Ne hangisi olabilir?
Bir şehirde kayıtlı olan binek
otomobillerin ortalama yaşı. Tamam. Bu
otomobille ilgili bir mevzu. O zaman 3'ü
D ile eşleştirdim. Teknoloji ile ilgili
ne var bakalım? Bir ülkede internet
kullanımının ortalama günlük süresi.
Evet. Bunu teknolojiye bağlayabiliriz.
4'ü C'ye bağladım. Beslenme ile ilgili
de ne olabilir? E Bursa'da ne var? Bak
yıllık balık tüketimi. Kişi başına
düşen. O zaman bunu da ne yapabiliriz?
Birbirine bağlayabiliriz. Anlaştık. Hadi
devam. Bir soru daha. Şimdi ekonomi
konulu bir gerçek yaşam durumu için
ekonomi konulu aşağıda verilen tek nicel
değişkenli veri toplamayı gerektiren
bağlamlardan hangisi bu başlığa uygun
olmaz? Bu ünite, bu tema daha doğrusu
sözel bir tema biliyorsunuz. Yani buna
yapacak bir şey yok. Dolayısıyla bol bol
sizlerle konuşacağız bu serüvende 6.
temada. Dolayısıyla sayısal kısımlara da
geçeceğiz inşallah da. Başlangıcı biraz
böyle sıkıcı mıkıcı da gelmesin ha.
Tamam. Tarih dersi dinliyorsun ya onun
gibi düşün. Şimdi gençler mevzumuz
ekonomi. Aşağıdakilerden hangisi bu
başlığa uygun olmaz? Bakıyorum dünya
borsalarının geçen yıla göre artış
azalış yüzdelerinin
kıyaslanması. Bas bayağı ekonomi bu
borsa diyor zaten. Ekonomi ilişkili.
Tamam o zaman bun ekonomi başlığında bir
bağlam olabilir. Alım gücünün. Alım gücü
de neymiş? 10 yıl öncesine göre artış
yüzdesi bizde sürekli artıyor. Mesela
bizde alım gücümüz iyi.
Şimdi eee dolayısıyla alım gücünün 10
yıl öncesine göre artış yüzdesi demek
yine neye bağlıdır? Ekonomiye bağlıdır.
E ben bunu da tiklerim. Uygun. Peki
dövizdeki yıllık artış demiş. E tamam.
Döviz ekonomi zaten içeler. Bu da tamam.
En zengin 500 şirketin sıralanması.
Zaten zengin diyor. Ekonomiyle direkt
alakalı. Bu da tamam. Ama C'ye
baktığımda ne görüyorum? Bak. İnsanların
huzurlu olduğu illerin sıralaması. Şimdi
bunun ekonomiyile direkt alakalı
olduğunu söyleyemeyiz. Belki başka bir
sebepten dolayı huzurlular. Tamam. Her
şey para değil demenin matematikçesi bu.
Tamam mı? Dolayısıyla da C şıkkını
işaretledim. Ekonomi başlığına uygun
olmaz. Devam ediyorum. Şimdi araştırma
sorusu oluşturacağız. Artık buraya
geldik. Ama buna başlamadan önce tabii
sana üç tane tanımdan bahsedeceğim.
içerikte geçecek çünkü. Sonra ne
anlatıyor bu amca filan mevzuları
olmasın. Anlatalım. Şimdi evren ne
demek? Hani bizim arka sokaktaki bakkal
evren mi? Hayır. Evren dediğimiz şey biz
bir araştırma yapacağız ya. O araştırma
yapacağımız aslında
topluluk. Mesela işte X Anadolu
Lisesi'ndeki 9A sınıfı gibi. Bu bir
topluluktur. Evrendir benim için. Eee
yani çok büyük olmasına gerek yok. 30
kişi de olur. Evren. Yani benim
araştırma konuma bağlı. ya da Türkiye,
tüm Türkiye'nin her ili benim yine
evrenim olabilir. Yapacağımız
araştırmaya göre. İşte evren budur. Elde
edilen araştırma sonuçlarının
genellendiği topluluk. Değişken
dediğimiz şey de gözlemlenen elemanların
birinden diğerine değişen özellikler. Ne
bileyim göz rengi mesela değil mi? İşte
seninki mavi, benimki siyah falan.
Değişken budur. Göz rengi bir
değişkendir. X Y gibi de düşünebilirsin.
Peki değişebilirlik ne? E bu şimdi
değişken dedik ya. Bu değişkenin tabii
ki de bir dağılımda bulunan değerlerin
değişkenlerden dolayı birbirinden farklı
olması. Ne bileyim ya bu İzmir'de
yaşayanlar niye boyu uzun falan hani
sulak yerde yaşadıkları için mi?
Olabilir. Yani bunun gibi düşünebiliriz.
değişebilirlik ortama mesela bağlı ne
bileyim işte sulak yerde. Saçma sapan
bir örnek veriyorum bu arada ciddiye
alma da hani sulak yerde yaşadığı için
boyları daha uzun iyi sulanmışlar falan
ya bu şekilde eee ortama göre olabilir
ya da farklı birazdan detayına gireceğim
o yüzden çok spoiler vermeyeceğim
şimdiden. Eee bir sebepten ötürü
değişebilir özellikte olmasından
bahsediyoruz. Tamam mı? Yani
değişebilirlik mevzusu bu. Şimdi
teknical değişkenli veri toplamayı
gerektiren
istatistiksel araştırma sorularında
bulunması gereken özelliklerimiz vardır.
Biliyorsun. Şimdi bunları
detaylandıracağız. Bu özellikler
araştırma sürecinin sonraki aşamalarının
bizim için yani amacımıza uygun olmasını
da
sağlar. Esas mevzuya geliyoruz.
Araştırma sorusunun özelliklerine
başladım. Şimdi bu var ya çıkabilir
karşısına. Hani bilmiyorum
öğretmenleriniz hazırlarsa sınavı
mesela. eee, bu maddeleri yaz diyebilir
ya da birkaçını verip açıklamanı da
isteyebilir. Şimdi araştırma sorusu
yazacağız. Dedik ya biz mevzuya
başladık. Biz araştırma yapacağız ya.
İstatistiksel eee araştırmamızı
yapacağız. E ne lazım önce? Number one
soru lazım. Soru. Soru lazımsa bu
sorunun özellikleri olması lazım. Öyle
lamb kafana göre. Dingo'nun ağrı değil
oğlum burası. Matematik 9. sınıf
matematik müfredatı anlatıyoruz. Sorunun
özellikleri olacak. Bir net olacaksınız.
Amacınız net olacak. Tamam mı? Sorunun
amacı betimleyen veya karşılaştıran
türde olmasıdır. Yani rastgele soru
hazırlayamazsın. Bir karşılaştırmalı,
bir betimlemeli, net bir şekilde
açıklanmalı. Yani buna sen özet olarak
şunu söyleyebilirsin. Amacın net olmalı.
Bir. İkincisi, araştırmaya da değer
olmalı. Böyle her soruyu kabul etmiyoruz
dedik ya. Araştırmaya da değer olmalı.
Mesela bir sınıftaki kız ve erkeklerin
kilo değerlerini karşılaştırmak için
oluşturulan araştırma sorusu bağlama
göre anlamlı bilgiler verir. İşte
kızların, erkeklerin kilo değerlerini
eee karşılaştırmak evet bize bir eee
anlamlı araştırmaya değer bir sonuç
verecektir. Dolayısıyla araştırmaya
değer ikinci maddemiz. Üçüncüsü
ilgilenilen grup açık. Evrenimiz açık
olmalı. Net. Yani ne diyoruz? Araştırma
sorusunun kimin veya neyin hakkında
olduğu belirtilmeli. Mesela şöyle bir
soru olmaz. Kız erkeklerin kilo
değerlerini karşılaştıracağım. Kimin,
nerenin? Hangi evrende? Avrupa'yı mı?
Türkiye'yi mi araştırıyorsun? 9A
sınıfını mı araştırıyorsun? Dolayısıyla
evrenimiz de yine bu soru içerisinde
açık bir şekilde belirtilmeli. Tamam mı?
Evren açık olmalı. Dördüncüsü değişken
açık şekilde yine belirtilmeli. Mesela
kilo diyoruz değil mi? Kilo bir
değişkendir. Net. Ama sen bunu vermeden
lambur lumbur yine soru hazırlayamazsın.
Araştırma sorusunun hangi veriler
hakkında olduğunu da net bir şekilde
soru içerisinde görmemiz lazım. Tamam.
Geçtim bir diğerine. 5. maddem. Burada
da ne diyoruz? Veri toplanarak
cevaplanabilmeli. Heh. Önemli
değerlerden biri de bu. Yani soru
oluşturduk ya. E bunun için bir veri
toplayabileceğimiz soru olması lazım.
Anlaştık mı? Burada da iki tür veri var.
Birincisi birincil veriler. Ne demek bu?
Soruyu ben yazdım, ben çizdim, ben
araştıracağım demek. Yani sen kendini,
kendi sorunu, eee, araştırmacılar
tarafından direkt toplanıyorsa siz
mesela araştırmacısınız, direkt gidip
topluyorsanız bu birinci verilerdir.
Tamam. Direkt sen alıyorsun. Araştırmaya
yönelik verilerin araştırmacılar
tarafından toplanması birincil veriler.
Ama tamam biz soruyu hazırladık. Sonra
da boynumuza astık. Biz dünyanın en
beleşçi
insanlarıyız diyerek gidip başkalarının
önceden topladığı verileri alarak
cevaplandırmaya çalışıyorsan buna da ne
diyoruz? İkincil, beleşçil veriler.
Tamam mı? Yani ikincil, birincil fark
etmez. Araştırma sorusu verilerle
cevaplanabilmelidir. Tamam mı? Çok
gömdük ama ikincil verilerle de tabii ki
de araştırma yapılabilir. Şimdi en
önemli yere geldim. Değişebilirliği
yansıtmalıdır. Şimdi dedik ya hani en
başta anlatmıştık değişebilirlik
tanımını. Bu
değişebilirlik 4 kaynaklı oluyor. Nasıl?
Mesela doğal ortamdan kaynaklı
değişebilirlik oluyor. İzmir'de adam
sulak yerde büyümüş. Boyu uzun olabilir.
Sallıyorum. İç Anadolu'da su yok. Daha
kısa kalmış falan. Hani ortamdan
kaynaklı bir değişebilirlik söz konusu
olabilir ya da ne bileyim ölçümden
kaynaklı. Mesela futbolda hakemler kendi
kafalarına göre adım sayıyorlar. Baraj
kuruyorlar ya 9 met 15 cm olacak. Ah
yersen adım atıyor 9 oluyor 7 metre
oluyor falan. İşte bu ölçümden kaynaklı
kendisinin yaptığı ölçümden kaynaklı
değişebilirlik. Tamam. Müdahaleden
kaynaklı değişebilirlik. Yani ben
müdahale edebilirim. İki ağaçtan
bahsediyoruz mesela. Bir ağacın daha
uzun olması için ona basarım vitaminini,
işte gübresini, azotunu, bilmem nesini
coştururum. Ne yaptım ben? Müdahale
ettim. Müdahaleden kaynaklı bir
değişiklik olabilir. Olmaya daabilir.
Yani mevzu zaten araştırıyoruz bunları.
Örneklemden kaynaklı değişebilirlik
olabilir. Şimdi 9A, 9B'yi
kapıştırıyoruz. Futbol maçı yapacak. E
9A 16-0 yeniyor. Neden acaba? E oradaki
örneklemden kaynaklı olabilir mi? Yani
9A'nın eee elemanları belli ki topçu.
Futbolu seviyorlar belli ki. Onlar daha
iyi oynuyorlar. Yani kişilerden
örneklemden. Örneklem demek şu. Oradaki
kişiler tamam mesela 9A, 9B dedik ya. E
9A'daki elemanlar demek ki daha iyi
oynuyorlar. Kişilerden kaynaklı bir
değişebilirlik olabilir. Onu
anlatıyoruz.
Tamam. Bunun sorularını çözeceğiz. Zaten
esas mevzu dediğim gibi buralardan
geliyor sorular. Detaya gireceğiz.
Sorularımızı çözeceğiz. Şimdi bir diğeri
odaklanılan grup araştırma yapılmasına
imkan vermelidir. Yani örneğin bir
grupta kimin en uzun olduğu sorusu bizim
için uygun değildir. Kim en uzun? O
bitti. Bu araştırma yapıldı mı?
Araştırma yapılmaya bir imkan
tanımadınız. En uzun dediniz bizim sırık
orada duruyor. Bu araştırma imkan
vermedi bana. Ama şunu yapabiliriz.
uygun olan şu: Gruptaki kişilerin
boylarının merkezinin nasıl eğilim
gösterdiği. Hani hepsinin boylarını bir
araştırırım, toplarım. Sonra da işte
nereye yakınsıyor? Hani hangi
santimetrede daha fazla yoğunluk var
gibi bir sonuca odaklanmamız lazım.
Anlatabiliyor muyum? O yüzden soru
araştırma yapmaya imkan vermeli bize. En
uzun bu işte deyip geçmemeliyiz. Kısa
net şekilde cevabı olmamalı. Bir
araştırma yapmalıyız. Koşturacağız,
terleyeceğiz. Azıcık emek harcayacağız.
Mevzu bu. Ve son olarak nicel veri
toplamaya uygun olmalıdır. Mesela boy
uzunluğu. Tamam. İşte nicel veri neydi?
Sayısal değer. E tamam mı? Boy uzunluğu
sayısal. O 1.68, o 1.70, 1 80 falan.
Bunları toplamaya uygun olmalı. Tamam.
elde edilecek veriler bir grubun belli
bir özelliğinin sayılması ve ölçülmesi
ile elde edilen veriler olmalıdır. Yani
9A'daki 9A'la 9B duygusallık eee
karşılaştırması mesela yapılamaz, değil
mi? Sayısal bir veri alamam ben oradan.
Kim daha duygusal, kim değil falan. Bu
bizim için uygun bir araştırma sorusu
olmaz. Araştırma sorusunda sayısal
veriler
toplayabilmeliyiz. Anlaştık. Haydi o
zaman örneğimize bakalım. Sorumuzu
çözelim. Şimdi burada ne var? Yukarıdaki
kutulardan birinde tek nicel
değişkenli
istatistiksel araştırmaya yön verecek
araştırma sorularını oluşturmak için
gerekli olan değişebilirlik türleri var.
Eee nerede o değişebilirlik türlerimiz?
Şurada. Tamam. Diğerinde de bu türlerden
her birine ait örnekler rastgele
verilmiş. Biz bunları ne yapacağız?
Doğru bir şekilde eşleştireceğiz. Hemen
başlayalım. Şimdi ilk cümlem birincisi
bir öğrenci sınıfın sıcaklığını gün boyu
farklı zamanlarda 5 kere ölçmüş ve her
defasında farklı bir değer bulmuş. Şimdi
sen öğrencisin. Sınıfın sıcaklığını
ölçüyorsun. Bir günde beş kör ölçtün ve
her defasında farklı bir değer buldun.
Bu neden kaynaklı olabilir? Yani bu
değişebilirliğin yani ölçümlerin sonucu
sürekli farklı geliyor. Neden kaynaklı
olabilir? Yani bu değişebilirliğin
sebebi ne?
doğal ortam. Sen şimdi e sabah ne
bileyim öyle bir karasal iklimde mi?
Karasal iklim miydi o? Coğrafyacılar
cevap verin. Eee karasal iklimdeydi
sanırım. Hani sıcaklık değişimi çok
hızlı oluyor. Gece gündüz arası mesela.
Şimdi arkadaş geldi eleman sabah ölçtü
buz gibi. Eee gittikçe ne bileyim ısındı
hava birden. Çok büyük bir değişim oldu.
E son ölçümü 5 ölçümü mesela daha sıcak
oldu. E bunun sebebi doğal ortamdan
kaynaklı işte karasal iklim olan bir
yerde ölçüm yapıyordur. Ondan dolayı
olabilir gibi. Tamam. Dolayısıyla 1'i A
ile eşleştirdim. Şimdi 2'ye bakalım.
Diğer koşulları aynı olan iki zeytin
fidanından iki zeytin fidanımız var.
Birinin köküne gübre atılmış diğerine
atılmamış. Tamam mı? Bir bu iki fidanın
boyu dikildikten sonra 6 ay boyunca her
ay ölçülmüş ve gübre atılan daha hızlı
uzamış. Ne var burada? Ben mühil oldum.
Oğlum iki tane fidem vardı mis gibi.
Kendi onlar kendi çapına büyüyecekti.
Ama ne yaptım? Birine gittim gübre
attım. O zaman ne yaptım? Müdahale
ettim. Tamam mı? Bak bu şekilde kafanda
kodla. O zaman ikinci arkadaşı kime
gönderiyoruz? C'ye gönderiyoruz. Tamam.
Geldim 3'e. 30 cmlik bir cetvelle bir
çubuğun uzunluğunu 5 kere ölçen bir kişi
her defasında birbirinden farklı
sonuçlar
bulmuş. O zaman yani bu elemanda sıkıntı
var diyebilir miyiz? Hayır, elemanda
değil. Ölçümden kaynaklı değişebilirlik
var burada. Yani ölçüyor ama sürekli
farklı ölçüyor. Demek ki tam hizasını
tutturamıyor olabilir. Cetveli koyuyor.
Şimdi cetveli ölçtün değil mi? Burayı
kaydırıp bir daha ölçeceksin. Ne oluyor
orada? 35 cm her defasında kayabilir.
İlk başta verdiğim örnek işte hakemler
mesela eee baraj kuruyorlar. Serbest
vuruş topu koydu. 9 met 15 cm ileri
gidecek. Oraya da işte rakip takımın
topçuları gelecek. Baraj kuracaklar
engel olması için. Kızlara anlatıyorum
bunu. Tamam. Erkekler hemen hocam
biliyor zaten demesin. Şimdi eee orada o
hakem 9 met 15 cm cetvelle ölçmüyor. Eee
adımlarıyla ölçüyor. E ne oluyor? Her
defasında farklı sonuçlar bulabilir
değil mi? Hatta bulabiliyor. Dolayısıyla
işte bunun sebebi ölçümden kaynaklı
değişebilirlik. Bu da beni nereye
götürüyor? 3'ün D''ye eşlendiğini
götürüyor. Sonuncusu çıktı ortaya. Ama
yine de bakalım. Bir sınıftan seçilen
iki öğrencinin matematik karne
notlarının birbirinden farklı olduğu
görülmüş.
biri daha çalışkan olduğu için olabilir
mi? Yani kişiden kaynaklı. Bak burada
örneklemi o örnek k'sinden aklında kişi.
Kişi demek tamam mı? Kişiden kaynaklı
değişebilirdik. Yani bireylerden dolayı.
Dolayısıyla da 4'ü Bursa'ya götürdüm.
Bunların hepsi nerede var? 4 Bursa'da,
A1'de, C2'de, D3'te. Tamam. A şıkkında
hepsini tertemiz görüyoruz. Gördüğün
gibi her birinden tüm e değişebilirlik
sebeplerinden bir örnek de vermiş olduk
bu soruyla. Hadi birkaç soru daha
yapalım. Şimdi burada bir atletizm
kulübünün antrenörü 12 tane genç
oyuncusunu altışar kişiden oluşan iki
takıma rastgele ayırmış ve daha sonra bu
kişilerin 100 metre koşusunda yaptıkları
en iyi dereceleri belirleyerek ortalama
dereceleri hesaplamış. Şimdi ne
yapıyorsun? Senin elinde 12 öğrenci var.
İşte 6ışardan iki takım kuruyorsun.
Sonra bu arkadaşları 100 metre
koşturacağım. Koş koş koş koş. Ve en iyi
dereceleri yazıyor. Tamam. Bunun da
sonra en son ortalamasını alıyor. Mesela
birinci takımın ortalaması, ikinci
takımın ortalaması. Soru şu oğlum bu
ortalama dereceler neden farklı
çıktı? Neden farklı çıktı? Bak şurada
sebeplere geri gel. Doğal ortamdan
kaynaklı mı? E hayır. İkisi de aynı
ortamda. Örneklemden kaynaklı mı?
Örneklem ne demek? Kişiler demek. E
burada tabii ki de örneklemden kaynaklı
bir sorun var. Yani sorun demeyelim,
sorun ne alaka ya? Bir değişim var.
Tamam. O yüzden cevap
örneklemden kaynaklı. Anlaştık
mı? Yani belli ki ikinci takımdaki
elemanlar daha hızlı koşuyor. Buradan o
sonuca varıyoruz. Tamam. Yani ikinci
takımın üstüne oynaması lazım. Bir sorum
daha var.
Bir öğretmen evinden okula yürüyerek
gelen öğrencilerden evleri ile okul
arasındaki uzaklığı kendi adımları ile 5
gün boyunca ölçmelerini istemiş.
Aşağıdaki tabloda Feyza kardeşimizin
yaptığı ölçümler var. Feyza her ölçümde
evi ile okulu arasındaki uzaklığı neden
farklı bulmuştur? Ölçüm sonuçları
sürekli farklı. Tabii Feyza ne bilsin bu
işin bir 9. sınıf sorusuna dönüşeceğini.
Ona göre belki ciddiyetle ölçerdi ama
ciddiyetle ölçmemiş. Yani ölçümden
kaynaklı bir sorun var. Örneklem diyemem
bak burada. Neden? Çünkü Feyza bir kişi.
Hani bir kişi daha olsa Feyza daha iyi
diğeri daha kötü gibi bir karşılaştırma
yapabiliriz. Ama burada zaten tek kişi
var. Feyza var. Feyza ölçüyor. Direkt
eylemi yapan Feyza. Tamam. E dolayısıyla
buradaki sıkıntı Feyza'nın ölçümü. Hani
önceki soruda da vardı ya cetvelle
ölçüyordu. E onu ölçen arkadaşımız güzel
ölçememiş. Ölçümden
kaynaklı fark var. Tamam. Yine doktor
yazımla eee sebebini yazdım. Ölçümden
kaynaklı diye cevabımızı verdik. Bak bu
sorular yazılıda tam gelecek sorular
haberiniz olsun. Yani verilen bilgilerle
o bilgiler ışığında sebebi zaten dör
tane şeyimiz var şurada bak hepsi
toparlanmış soruda. Buradan bakarak da
mevzuya sonuca ulaşabilirsiniz dedim. Bu
dersimi burada bitirdim. Tamam yine
çenemiz düşmüş. Kısa bir konu ama önemli
bir konuydu. Buradan yine devam
edeceğiz. Tabii ki de yorumlarınız,
beğenileriniz eee bizleri motive eden en
büyük kaynaklardan, sebeplerden biri.
Dolayısıyla sizler de bunu bizden mahrum
bırakmayın diyor. Dersi bitiriyorum.
Hadi bir sonraki ders. Yeniden
görüşünceye dek o zaman kendinize çok
iyi bakın ve matematikle kalın. Hoşça
kalın.